[Music]
your kids i just want they're they're
well they're you guys are already a
seven-year-old five-year-old
two-year-old and an eight-month-old so
it's uh
a lot of kids and uh they uh you know my
kids are starting to to you know it's
nice now because they're old enough now
they can like write yeah we we've been
doing that yeah you want to it's true
for a long time they don't write and
then suddenly people
don't have kids
it's like they can get a book deal you
know
yeah i'm making a lot of scratch off
these kids you know it's like we we told
them to get a packet together we'll
submit it to sesame street no i uh
but you know you want to have an active
participation in your children's life
and so i'm always encouraging my you
know my five-year-old is is starting to
write and it's amazing the level of
sarcasm that you will see at such a
young age and um my son he you know he
would write something and he would show
me and i and i and i took a picture of
one of the things that he wrote maybe we
can take a look at it here look at this
dad you are fat
[Applause]
and you know but the thing is is like
it's not like i'm not fat
and you know but it's i love the sarcasm
and you know so we've been working on it
and so we have made some improvements
you've made progress we've made some
progress we can take a look at where is
one of us dad is fast
i mean he's doing much better first of
all it's gone from like a text message
to a complete sentence yeah yeah and the
le is led it's very legible yeah it's
good it's all caps it's he's yelling it
i'm impressed by it
are you i'm sure you're taking a lot of
photos lately
you know it's it's
i i think our whole culture we have to
settle down with the with the picture
taking we take pictures of everything
and it's like it's like we act like
we're capturing history unbelievable the
cat's taking a nap let's take a picture
it's
it's we it's because we have the cameras
on our phones do we need that it's not
as if 10 years ago we were like i wish i
could take a low quality photo of my
dessert
post it on my twitter page
if only and we have all these photos now
it's like i don't know what we're
supposed to do with them i mean except
for make our computers run slow
it's i have more pictures of my children
than my father ever looked at me
[Laughter]
i keep taking them i keep taking them
you know we used to have boxes of photos
in our closets now it's just old
computers yes you know it's like ah
there's our wedding computer
there's my computer when i was single
i should probably destroy that one
now you uh you uh obviously you have a
lot of fans you have die hard fans and
they send you strange
things and i i am i told you you brought
us some photos i brought some photos you
know it's it's these are real it's very
flattering i know it's it's it's
consistent on your show and
and it's some of them are inspired by
jokes that i i used to have this joke a
long time ago this character this rosco
the wood guy yeah and so after a show uh
someone brought me this and i just loved
it and it kind of started it's you
carved in wood yes
and what i love about this is it's a
it's a correct proportion of the size of
head to body yes
you and i have obviously we did a a a
cartoon collaboration called pale force
called pale force ashley uh you it was
you uh uh dragging me
i never uh
still bitter you never gave me a
creative say in how i was depicted
you know look at look at that look how
you do you decided how you were depicted
that's that's a pretty fair
representation yeah
i mean i don't have a beard you're right
so um
but otherwise that's spot on and of
course pale force was the idea of paul
north is a friend of mine who's a
cartoonist at the new yorker and
but this is uh my favorite gift that
i've received from people that have come
to shows and i i wanted to show you this
is from uh i received this i believe in
kansas city and this is sock monkey sock
monkey pale force this is it if you can
hold that this is me this is you and
then
she did also she did conan
and
i think it's
why am i wearing
why am i wearing ballet slippers
she she was trying to butcher up a
little bit i think
man we are out of time